[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday Hank I
don't really have any particular topic
to talk about today because I'm still
sort of like awash in the joy of having
finished the revision of my book so I
thought I would draw out the intro as
long as possible
Hank I'd like to begin today by
congratulating you on your excellent
song yesterday and also on your one-year
anniversary with Katherine I don't
exactly know what the proper thing to do
for you on the occasion of your one-year
anniversary is but I do have some
leftover silly string ah it's not really
string so much is it's like little dots
Hank I'd like you to observe what just
came out of the bottle of wacky string
that's not wacky string that's like
wacky irregular polygon congratulations
Hank in your song yesterday when you
were listing all the ways that you're
incredibly lucky I couldn't help but
notice that there was one kind of luck
that you have that you failed to mention
in the song I am of course specifically
referring to how lucky you are to have a
brother like me on the mat it didn't
hurt my feelings it's just something
that I happen to notice but regardless
of your cruel unwillingness to
acknowledge the luck that is your
brother I'm so so so happy for you and
Katherine after one year of marriage I
mean not only are you lucky to have
married Katherine I am also lucky that
you married Katherine because she's
great incidentally Hank it's not until
you have a bunch of green stuff on your
forehead that you begin to notice how
much forehead you really have Hank in
other news we have a serious happy dance
problem and I don't know if you're aware
of it Hank as you know we're currently
collecting happy dance videos from all
the nerdfighters those happy dance
videos can be sent to sparks fly up at
gmail.com the deadline for these happy
dances is October 1st now Hank I'm not a
mathematician but I called Brotherhood
2.0 resident mathematician Daniel Biss
and he says that October 1st is
potentially as little as 10 days away
now Hank we've gotten more than 100
happy dance videos which is pretty
incredible until you consider the fact
that there are more than 6 billion
people in the world which means that
there are literally more than 6 billion
happy dances that are still unrecorded
now Hank I realize that not everyone has
a camcorder but you don't even need a
camcorder to do this these days all you
really need is a phone so I hope all
nerdfighters everywhere work hard to
send us their happy dances by the way
Hank do you know the
group of nerdfighters were on TV holding
a sign outside the Today Show that said
nerdfighters also in nerdfighter news
ever since I started watching the videos
of our secret Australian niece and
nephew Natalie and Calvin I always find
myself saying no if I toes I want to
have a kid they're so little and cute
it's like they have the same amount of
awesome that's inside of a regular
person only it's compacted into a tiny
little adorable package unfortunately
when the Yeti comes home and she sees
all that congealed wacky string on the
carpet I suspect that the baby date will
be moved back at least a year I can just
hear the lecture now I'm not going to
have a baby until my husband stops
playing with wacky string but I can't
help myself
I think it's so fun oh I'm 30 Hank again
happy Anniversary and I'll see you
tomorrow
they never specifically say on the back
of the wacky string tube that you
shouldn't spray it onto your own hair
but I can feel it eating away at my
scalp it's like the selsun blue tingle
only Bernie er